The "Odyssey" itself is a sequel to Homer's other famous epic, the "Iliad,"...
...which tells the story of the Trojan War.
If there's one major theme uniting both poems, it's this:...
...Do not, under any circumstances, incur the wrath of the gods.
The Greek Pantheon is a dangerous mix of divine power....
...and human insecurity, prone to jealousy and grudges of epic proportions.
And many of the problems faced by humans in the poems...
...are caused by their hubris,...
...or excessive pride in believing themselves superior to the gods.
The "Odyssey" recounts all of Odysseus's years of travel,...
...but the narrative begins in medias res, in the middle of things.
Ten years after the Trojan War, we find our hero trapped on an island,...
...still far from his native Ithaca...
...and the family he hasn't seen for 20 years.
Because he's angered the sea god Poseidon by blinding his son, a Cyclops,...
...Odysseus's passage home has been fraught with mishap after mishap.
With trouble brewing at home and gods discussing his fate,...
...Odysseus begins the account of those missing years to his hosts.
One of the most fascinating things about the "Odyssey"...
...is the gap between how little we know about its time period...
...and the wealth of detail the text itself contains.
Historians, linguists, and archeologists have spent centuries...
...searching for the ruins of Troy...
...and identifying which islands Odysseus visited.